-Damning new documentary footage
of key Trump ally, Roger Stone,
discussing plans
for a violent coup to overturn
the 2020 election has emerged
thanks to the committee
investigating the January 6th
insurrection.
Meanwhile, the committee
is still reportedly
debating some of its biggest
unanswered questions,
including whether to subpoena
Mike Pence or Trump himself.
For more on this,
it's time for a closer look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The committee investigating
the January 6th attack
on the Capitol
was supposed to have held
its ninth public hearing today,
but delayed the hearing due
to Hurricane Ian.
The delay also gives
the committee more time
to resolve
some major questions,
namely whether or not
to subpoena key figures
like Mike Pence
or even Donald Trump himself.
-Preparations for the hearing
come at a critical moment
for the committee with very big
unanswered questions
for the committee's members
as they prepare to wrap
its work up
by the end of the year.
From "The New York Times"
quote --
"The panel whose public hearings
this summer exposed
substantial new details
about former
President Donald J. Trump's
efforts to reverse the outcome
of the 2020 election
must still decide whether to
issue subpoenas to Mr. Trump
and former VP Mike Pence.
And it must still grapple with
when to turn its files over
to the Justice Department,
how to finish what it hopes
will be a comprehensive
written report
and whether to make criminal --
I'm gonna say it again --
criminal referrals."
-Don't worry, you don't need
to say it again.
The only referrals Trump
is getting these days
are criminal referrals.
Can you imagine someone writing
a job referral for Trump?
I can't imagine Trump gets
many customer referrals either.
I doubt any of his businesses
will be getting any
five-star reviews on Yelp
unless it's from
one of his weirdo pals.
[ Laughter ]
You know it.
Anyway, I gotta be honest.
If I was on the committee,
I'm not sure where I'd land
on the question
of whether to subpoena Trump.
I mean, on the one hand,
it would be great to get him
under oath on camera
so you could make him
answer questions
in front of the American public
under the threat of perjury.
On the other hand, he's not
gonna answer questions
under threat of perjury.
Putting Trump on the stand
is as good an idea
as putting a chimpanzee
in a school play.
He's not gonna stick
to the script.
Yeah, the beginning was fun
when the monkey
came out in a costume,
but then it got weird and scary.
Trump can't even answer softball
questions from his friends
on Fox News without going off
on deranged tangents.
Here's a quick highlight reel
from a softball interview
he did with Sean Hannity
last week.
And I should note,
none of the answers here
had anything to do with the
questions that preceded them.
-You could go all over Hollywood
and try
and get somebody to play
the role of President Xi,
the president of China.
There is no actor like that.
There's nobody like that.
The media said,
"Why does he call this person?"
I call this person, because
that's where the action is.
Letitia James, she had a --
she had a focus on murder
and crime in New York,
where they walk
into stores with axes,
and they start swinging
the axes at people.
They wanted to rip down
all the statues in this country,
including
the Jefferson Memorial,
the Lincoln Memorial.
I mean, it's not
even believable.
-No, it's not.
You want us
to believe protesters
were gonna try to tear
down the Lincoln Memorial?
It seems like that's the most
topple-proof statue we got.
That's how smart Lincoln was.
They said, "We're gonna make
a statue of you standing up."
And he said,
"Nah, dawg, I'm too tall.
I'm too tall
and skinny for that,
a strong breeze
would take me down,
put me in a wide-ass chair.
I'm just going to sit down
low in a big old chair.
Get my butt down
in the cushion.
Best of luck, protesters."
Also, what the hell is
Trump talking about
when he says people in
New York City are swinging axes?
Did they accidentally watch
"House of the Dragon"
and think it was the news?
[ Imitating Trump ] Have you
seen what's happening
in New York City?
People are wearing gold cloaks.
They're having sword fights.
They put a ponytail
on Doctor Who.
It's so sad.
Doctor Who --
I would never in
a million years -- Doctor Who.
I saw that,
I said, "Doctor what?"
And they have him --
New York City has
a major dragon problem.
Letitia James, you know, she's
--
they should be doing
something about the dragons.
[ Normal voice ] Can you imagine
that guy sitting down
for a televised
congressional hearing?
It would take days.
The networks would have
to preempt all their programing
just so Trump could ramble
about statues or ax murderers
or windmills or toilets
that don't flush.
Although it would be nice
to get him under oath
about the toilets
he's always talking about.
Mr. President,
you have repeatedly said
you have to flush toilets
10 times,
15 times because of
the lack of water pressure.
Is that actually true?
[ Imitating Trump ] Yes.
[ Normal voice ]
Is it possible, sir,
that rather
than being the toilet's fault?
They are, in fact,
not designed to flush letters
from dictators and manila
envelopes full of state secrets?
[ Imitating Trump ] I would like
to plead the Fifth.
[ Normal voice ] So there are
still some key decisions
remaining for the January 6th
committee to make.
But what they've already
discovered has been shocking.
And there's apparently
more to come.
For example, one of the central
characters in the next hearing
was supposed to have been
Trump ally Roger Stone.
And now we have damning
new documentary footage of Stone
openly discussing plans
for a violent coup
before the 2020 election.
Stone laid out in detail months
before the election
how the Trump team would refuse
to accept the results,
claim the election was stolen,
and use the courts
to overturn the results
and even throw out
the real electors
who showed up
to the Electoral College,
count on January 6th,
and replace
them with phony Trump electors.
-What they're assuming is that
the election will be normal.
The election will not be normal.
Oh, these are
the California results.
Sorry, we're not accepting them.
We're challenging them in court.
If you like to show up
at the Electoral College.
Armed guards
will throw them out.
I'm the president [Bleep] you.
You're not stealing Florida.
You're not stealing --
I'm challenging all of it.
And the judges we're going to
are judges I appointed.
[Bleep] you, you're not stealing
the election.
-Why do these guys all explain
their criminal schemes out loud
and highly specific details
before they do them?
I want to make sure there's
a camera here before I start.
They're like Bond villains
spelling out
exactly how they're gonna
kill him
right before he slips out
of his handcuffs.
Just don't get tips
on being a bad guy
from Christoph Waltz.
[ Imitating Waltz ]
You see, James,
you will have your hands
tied to this chain
from where you will dangle above
a pool of sharks
while I hack into
the Bank of England,
and -- Oh, wait, he's gone.
[ Normal voice ] Now, just
a quick little sidenote here.
As I've explained before, some
of our less charitable viewers
have complained that
my Christoph Waltz
sounds more like Werner Herzog.
And to those people,
I would just like to say.
-[Bleep] you.
[ Laughter ]
-Not only
does it not sound
like Werner Herzog,
it barely sounds
like Christoph Waltz.
[ Laughter ]
Also a bizarre detail in
this whole Roger Stone thing
is that he gave these interviews
to a Danish film crew
for a documentary
for some reason.
In fact, CNN interviewed
the Danish filmmakers this week
who explained that staffers
for the January 6th committee
also visited them in Copenhagen
as part of their investigation
into the coup attempt.
-Joining me now, the filmmakers
of "A Storm Foretold".
Christoffer Gulbrandsen is the
film's director and producer,
and Frederik Marbell
is the director of photography.
You were contacted
and then subpoenaed
by the January 6th committee.
What happened when they came?
They came to
meet you in Copenhagen, right?
-Correct.
-What happened?
-Well, they came four lawyers
from the committee
and questioned us
for four days.
And we then had a discussion
about what their point
of interests were
and what they were looking into.
And we tried to accommodate what
they needed to do their work.
-After everyone
on the January 6th committee
has had to talk to,
it must've been so pleasant
to chat with
Danish documentary filmmakers.
I mean, they've had to depose
Bill Barr, Rudy Giuliani,
that ghost that died and came
back as an even paler ghost.
Also, hats off
to the January 6th staffers
who managed to convince
their bosses that they needed
to go to Copenhagen
to get this footage.
You could have probably
just sent an e-mail.
Hey, Mr. Chairman, there's
a damning footage of Roger Stone
planning the coup in Copenhagen,
and the the file
is too big to e-mail.
So, yeah.
So we were thinking maybe
the only way to get it
is to backpack
through Europe for a month.
We promise to come back
with evidence
and one of those super-fun
pictures where it looks like
we're holding up
the Leaning Tower of Pisa.
[ Laughter ]
We'll wear a suit for it.
Yeah, we're gonna
take a Eurail,
but we're gonna pack,
like, a super-formal suit
for that picture where we hold
up the Leaning Tower of Pisa.
[ Laughter ]
But it's insane -- [ Laughs ]
Because, you know --
[ Cheers and applause ]
But as insane and incriminating
as all of this is,
nothing is more head-scratching
to me than Stone's response
to the release
of the documentary footage.
He claims the footage
is manipulated
and bizarrely compared himself
to Kim Kardashian.
-Roger Stone has issued
a lengthy statement
disputing the authenticity
of all of them,
saying this...
-I mean, I'd say you have more
in common with Alanis Morissette
neither of you seem
to understand
the definition of ironic.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, what the hell
is he talking --
Did someone manipulate a video
of Kim Kardashian
to make it look
like she was planning a coup
when we all know that would
totally be a Khloé move?
Also, when a Kardashian
plots a coup,
do you think they spell coup
with a K?
I think maybe.
But here's the thing.
Stone's call to the violence
wasn't just idle chatter.
In addition to his friendship
with Trump,
he's also had ties to right wing
militia groups
like the Oath Keepers,
whose members are on trial right
now for seditious conspiracy.
A few weeks ago,
the January 6th committee
even released real-time audio
they'd obtained of Oath Keepers
communicating
during the insurrection
using a walkie-talkie app.
Some of the memories
you'll hear in this clip
were there in person
while others
were watching on television
and relaying what
they were seeing.
And specifically, they discussed
one of Trump's tweets
during the attack,
which they interpreted
as essentially
giving them permission
to go after members of Congress.
Also, I would like to note
that as menacing as they sound,
they are also clearly
giant [Bleep]
-Wow, I can't believe
the doofus sitting at home
watching TV with a walkie talkie
turned out to be wrong.
Also, who's the lazy ass[Bleep]
who pulled the cushy assignment
to sit home
and watch the insurrection on TV
while everyone else had
to actually go out there
and do the rioting?
Good luck, guys. Looking pretty
friggin' radical down there.
Okay, they're going
to commercial.
Oh [Bleep] it's Magnum.
Oh, yeah.
I've got -- I've got Magnum
on my TV right now.
He's saying something
about a reverse mortgage,
and it's making a lot of sense
to me, guys.
Well, it's making a lot of sense
to me what he's saying.
We should be able to take
the money out of our own houses.
I will write down the phone
number so y'all have it.
Also, here is the most shocking
part, to me, about that clip.
-A pro-Trump militia member
was watching CNN.
I thought they were fake news.
Way to betray
the MAGA movement, dude.
Was he also secretly home
drinking chamomile,
wearing Birkenstocks,
and charging his Prius?
Seriously,
why weren't you watching Fox?
If you're a pro-Trump rioter,
you got to be
watching Fox because...
-That's where the action is.
-These guys all spelled out
in highly specific detail
what they were planning
on doing.
They admitted on camera
into a microphone over
and over and over again.
If you plotted a graph
with how many crimes
they committed over time,
the line would go straight up
along the y...
-Axes.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh [Bleep] Jesus Christ.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, good, encourage them.
Encourage the writers,
by all means, yeah.
This has been a closer look.
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up.
So to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at HeadCount.org
to check your voter
registration status
or to register to vote.